it is all about survivor right now and
on thursdays that's what it is today so
let's get into our weekly wrap
yes the best day of the week i love
survivor uh last night's episode was an
absolute roller coaster with two
castaways voted out of the game and on
to the jury and during this week's
second tribal council a conversation
about race completely changed the game
wow
look chanel goes out okay that's fine
that's one thing rockstar goes out
that's another person i write treya's
name out that's three black people in a
row okay and survivor isn't just about
strategic strategy it's not survivor is
also about bringing the social world big
into a small thing if i write drea's
name right now that means that i'm a
part of her perpetuating problem so like
the same thing over and over again and
again and again
i can't do it so like we can figure
something else out but i morally cannot
write her name down that's my idol so
you have to figure something out i knew
it was coming from me so that let's play
[Music]
i don't feel like this is right because
y'all are coming at this it's like
obviously my name is
don't make it seem like i'm being
aggressive you are being aggressive
this is the game
but the thing is yes it is a game but
there are subconscious bias that i might
have that you don't know because it is
subconscious and that that's saying that
i'm subconsciously racist
no i'm saying how we feel just because
i'm saying oh i feel at this moment does
not mean that you can make that your
problem this is my situation my issue
i'm addressing it the way i wanted to
address it and the reason i wanted to
play it was for representation
okay wow enjoying this right now is our
survivor correspondent and season 41
winner erica katsupadan how are you i'm
good we have a lot to talk about yeah
you think
[Laughter]
yes we do uh it's so nice to see you so
first of all i have to ask
what were your thoughts on that second
tribal and how
race played a role
you know what i think that i can't
really speak for drea or marianne in in
that moment and in their experience both
in the game and outside of the game i
think that as a viewer i really commend
both drea and marianne for their
vulnerability and for their courage and
i think that this is a perfect reminder
to the audience that survivor is a
social experiment and what makes it
amazing is we have these people from
different backgrounds and different
lived experiences going through these
complicated circumstances so i would
love to remind people as we watch a
conversation like this please watch it
from a place of empathy and curiosity
and not a place of judgment so do they
because you were there you won the show
do they
like
when these conversations and situations
happen because you get to have this
conversation on a platform or do they
hope that these situations never happen
on survivor
i think that it's a fine line but i
think that
what they want is for people to be real
and for people to be vulnerable and to
show who they really are because that's
what the audience is there to see
they're there to see these real people
so i think that when there are these
real moments it can be uncomfortable for
some people but i think that it can also
be really empowering and it can be a
learning moment for everybody
yeah no i totally agree uh and uh okay
so roxroy joining the jury was a uh
shock to the other half of the tribe but
pitching an all-male alliance oh come on
man definitely raise the red flag do you
think that led to his downfall i mean
the idea of an all-male alliance is kind
of funny because more men have one
survivor than women um but i did talk to
roxroy today and he said it wasn't an
all-men alliance it was an all-men
alliance plus drea and i think the
downfall the downfall from roxroy is he
has
acknowledged himself that he is not the
best social player i think that he
didn't lay down the social framework
needed in order to make that alliance
happen because you can pose an alliance
of any configuration of people to
someone that you don't have a strong
relationship with and they're going to
say what the hell right
yeah
yeah this episode changed a lot of
perceptions about certain players like
we caught glimpses of the cracks in
jonathan's armor lindsay's solid
strategic planning as well as displays
of bravery and vulnerability for
marianne andrea but what do you think
we'll see next you know we saw a lot in
this episode that made people think and
i think this is also an episode that's
really going to kind of
chip away at the foundation of where the
power is in the game i think we're going
to see people who were in a good
position now be in an uncomfortable
position i think that we're going to see
people who we thought had no power like
someone like a marian or a lindsay i
think we're going to start to see them
work their way up so i think that this
has really set off a chain reaction of
power moving around in the game and
we're going to see that unfold over the
next few episodes uh do you think that
the momentum could shift enough that a
person who was never thought would win
could wind up winning the whole thing i
mean you're preaching to the choir at
this point last season no one thought it
was me nobody now south nobody you think
it could happen again i think so yeah
awesome